Brazilian music is all about passion and joy and today we find out why.
We teach the instruments that are very popular in the north of Brazil,...
...in Salvador da Bahia.
It's separated between two categories.
The low, very low sound and the high sounds.
Salvador da Bahia is known for the low sounds we call the "fondo," the background.
It's like an earthquake.
We're specializing in groove.
We have one groove and we go from one site to another following the musical director.
So, do you think anyone could learn these instruments?
Of course!
Here, we're living in North America and we tend to think too much,...
...and rhythm is all about forgetting.
In order to be good at what you do, you have to be completely free to your instruments.
You have to learn from the inside.
In that way, what we do is a kind of meditation.
It's purely rhythm and we can play for two, three hours.
We teach these instruments all in relation to one another.
This instrument answers to this other one.
This one and this one and this one.
It's really a collective mentality where everybody is making the whole.